[ZH] 那我講,那家長可能看了報告之後
[ZH] 就會覺得好吧,那可能就是
[ZH] 那其實心理師做的事情
[ZH] 跟醫生做的事情也沒有差太多啦
[ZH] 他只是多了一個按電腦
[ZH] 然後可能跟他講比較久
[ZH] 然後也許會做個那個智力測驗
[ZH] 然後就是讓他待久一點
[ZH] 然後就會反照
[ZH] 那反照之後心理師的行為描述
[ZH] 就可以寫的比較多一點這樣
[ZH] 是這樣
[ZH] 所以我常常跟家長說
[ZH] 你為什麼會覺得說小孩來這邊才一次
[ZH] 然後這邊做一個小時
[ZH] 你就覺得心理師的觀察是準確的
[ZH] 我常常會很懷疑這件事情
[ZH] 那個CPT 說實話是讓我們去按
[ZH] 但是在一些比較輕微的
[ZH] 或是一些比較高智商的
[ZH] 他們做出來的CPT常常是正常的
[ZH] 就是跟你在一般日常生活中
[ZH] 你沒有觀察的完全不一樣
[ZH] 所以加上有時候也會蠻驚訝
[ZH] 為什麼他是做出來做得這麼好
[ZH] 原因就是因為他本身的那個
[ZH] 敏感度本來就沒有很高
[ZH] 然後再加上他那個
[ZH] 其實有些小孩就喜歡電腦見面嘛
[ZH] 他就覺得電腦見面有趣
[ZH] 他有那個成就感
[ZH] 他就給他就是還蠻專心在按
[ZH] 那有些小孩很好笑
[ZH] 他是在那邊按
[ZH] 然後就扭按扭去
[ZH] 扭按扭去按
[ZH] 然後這樣子
[ZH] 然後問心理師說好了沒這樣子
[ZH] 但是他按出來指標
[ZH] 還算在正常的範圍內
[ZH] 對
[ZH] 所以有時候心理師
[ZH] 他也會寫心理微觀察啦
[ZH] 雖然指標完全正常
[ZH] 但是他會告訴你說
[ZH] 欸他那天按的時候
[ZH] 其實蠻躁動的
[ZH] 然後不耐煩
[ZH] 然後還七分鐘的時候
[ZH] 就開始問心理說
[ZH] 哎,好了沒啊,怎麼那麼久啊,這樣子
[ZH] 那這個大概也是我們可以做診斷的一個參考
[ZH] 那所以就是說,如果說他很明顯的時候
[ZH] 我們在看門診完大概就可以診斷了
[ZH] 尤其是老師和新班老師、家長自己都這樣覺得
[ZH] 那大概就是可以去討論說
[ZH] 接下來我們要怎麼辦這樣子
[ZH] 你困擾到這個程度
[ZH] 那很多時候會可能需要用藥
[ZH] 那所以我們在講神經多樣性的時候
[ZH] 其實我們那時候精神醫學會有點擔心
[ZH] 因為我們有一陣子大家都在講去疾病話
[ZH] 就是覺得吃藥就是不好的
[ZH] 藥就是毒這樣子
[ZH] 但是我們自己在臨床上這樣子照顧下來
[ZH] 有些小孩子不讓他吃藥
[ZH] 真的是舉步難行
[ZH] 就是不知道要怎麼去安防他
[ZH] 因為他就是很難配合
[ZH] 有些比較小的小孩
[ZH] 我們當然就會讓他去做職能治療
[ZH] 可是有些職能治療師就說
[ZH] 媽媽我覺得她可能來吃藥
[ZH] 吃了藥再來做治療會比較好
[ZH] 因為她根本就沒辦法專心很久
[ZH] 那教師關維持她的秩序
[ZH] 她可能花20分鐘
[ZH] 那剩下10分鐘她能做什麼
[ZH] 那10分鐘的注意力又是非常零碎的
[ZH] 所以可能就是在那邊半個小時
[ZH] 什麼事情都沒有做到這樣
[ZH] 所以就是說
[ZH] 有時候還是需要讓她的大腦能夠
[ZH] 因為藥物有回覆到正常的功能
[ZH] 然後她才能正確地做她執行
[ZH] 執行功能該做的事情
[ZH] 它才能吸收、才能學習
[ZH] 然後才能增加它跟其他腦虛的連結
[ZH] 那你都不做的時候
[ZH] 你放任它在原始的狀態
[ZH] 真的是什麼事都很難做得到
[ZH] 會是被非常被非常被
[ZH] 然後都沒有辦這樣子
[ZH] 對,然後目前這個勝虛率大概5到10%
[ZH] 然後好像覺得有增加的趨勢
[ZH] 但事實上我覺得某部分
[ZH] 當然是它勝虛率真的有點增加
[ZH] 因為我們都市化得很嚴重
[ZH] 然後3C又用了很多
[ZH] 會讓它的症狀痕被凸顯出來這樣
[ZH] 那再來就是說其實覺察變得非常好
[ZH] 因為剛剛那個局長就說啦
[ZH] 我們就是融合教育嘛
[ZH] 所以那個老師在那個團體裡面
[ZH] 他遇到一些比較有一點點狀況的小朋友
[ZH] 他們會很快的覺察出來
[ZH] 像我們這麼一群人啊
[ZH] 如果有一個人椅子上面有來流去流去
[ZH] 非常的明顯
[ZH] 因為大家都很安靜
[ZH] 然後他就會被凸顯出來
[ZH] 所以老師在外上看是非常的顯著的
[ZH] 會比較敏感
[ZH] 那家長自己在家裡
[ZH] 因為他們常常一兩個小孩而已
[ZH] 他就不知道說
[ZH] 他這樣的表現到底是不是異常
[ZH] 因為他沒有一個常磨可以去做對照
[ZH] 所以有時候我們會蠻看重老師的一些觀察
[ZH] 那所以就是敏感度變多了
[ZH] 那所以他們就會比較把它推來治療
[ZH] 那當然有些家長會覺得說
[ZH] 現在老師什麼東西都疾病化
[ZH] 都叫你去看醫生
[ZH] 脾氣壞也叫你去看醫生
[ZH] 然後坐不住也叫你看醫生
[ZH] 學校也叫你看醫生
[ZH] 然後我就說
[ZH] 沒辦法啊
[ZH] 他們也沒辦法處發小孩啊
[ZH] 他們現在可以管教的工具非常的少
[ZH] 因為我們也希望說
[ZH] 因為現在小孩也真的很少
[ZH] 我們也希望說我們可以趕快
[ZH] 看出他的困難的地方
[ZH] 然後在他困難的地方
[ZH] 可以及時的給予協助
[ZH] 而不是用過去那一套那種打罵方式
[ZH] 以前沒有ADHD嗎
[ZH] 怎麼可能
[ZH] 以前就在放牛班和後段班
[ZH] 不是嗎
[ZH] 不想讀書好嗎
[ZH] 那你就是去後段班
[ZH] 你這樣讀書沒關係
[ZH] 你就在外面混啊
[ZH] 去逃學啊
[ZH] 然後去混公廟
[ZH] 以前不知道是工
[ZH] 以前是那個
[ZH] 以前往後面那麼發達
[ZH] 詐騙那種好轉的時候
[ZH] 都是去黑島嘛
[ZH] 對啊
[ZH] 就在外面那個跟人家在一起啊
[ZH] 那女生不會讀書的
[ZH] 就是在後段班啊
[ZH] 然後就一直被罵說
[ZH] 你就是不認真
[ZH] 你就是懶惰啊
[ZH] 你就是沒討厭啦
[ZH] 沒路由啊
[ZH] 這種的
[ZH] 對
[ZH] 那他們有時候可能
[ZH] 到國高中腦部比較成熟之後
[ZH] 自己發現
[ZH] 其實自己並沒有那麼笨
[ZH] 他們可能開始會去發展
[ZH] 自己的事業
[ZH] 那有些就發展得還不錯
[ZH] 好
[ZH] 那那個我們要講的是說
[ZH] 這個神經氓氓性疾病
[ZH] 它絕對都有生病的問題
[ZH] 那像ADHD的話
[ZH] 它可能是跟正身上腺素
[ZH] 跟多巴胺有關係這樣
[ZH] 那血清素的話
[ZH] 跟我們的焦慮憂鬱有一些關係
[ZH] 所以也會有相對應的藥物介入這樣
[ZH] 那ADHD目前大部分的講說是說
[ZH] 它的腦部成熟比較慢一點
[ZH] 尤其是在我們高階的比赤功能
[ZH] 就前額葉、額捏葉的部分
[ZH] 他們在mature的時間都比一般的小朋友可能晚2到5年這樣
[ZH] 所以他們在小時候會讓人家覺得他跟同齡的比起來
[ZH] 看起來就比較幼稚
[ZH] 做事情沒有思慮
[ZH] 然後好像不會去想事情的後果
[ZH] 然後也這樣恰恰留這樣子
[ZH] 那就會講說他比較慢
[ZH] 那他是不是後來就會好
[ZH] 這也是有點哀傷的事情
[ZH] 就是其實他會隨著年齡而改善
[ZH] 但是其實有些人他還是會殘存一些症狀
[ZH] 其實有一半的成年人他到成年期之後
[ZH] 他可能還是有一半的注意力的問題
[ZH] 會去影響他日常生活的執行
[ZH] 那成年人有時候會覺得困擾沒有那麼明顯
[ZH] 是因為他們可以自己選擇他們的工作
[ZH] 他可以因為自己覺得我就是喜歡手作
[ZH] 我就是不喜歡看很多文字
[ZH] 那我去做一些操作的工作
[ZH] 我就覺得我的障礙好像就比較不見了
[ZH] 但是雖然可能在日常生活
[ZH] 還是會丟三八四望東旺西這樣子
[ZH] 然後他可能會做一些業務
[ZH] 比如他做業務
[ZH] 他就可以一直跑來跑去
[ZH] 他就不需要在一個地方待很久
[ZH] 然後坐很久
[ZH] 那他過動的一些不舒服的感覺
[ZH] 可能就會比較消失
[ZH] 所以其實成人他就比較可以靠去
[ZH] 製造他自己周邊的環境
[ZH] 去減緩他自己的障礙
[ZH] 但是小孩就沒辦法
[ZH] 因為他被要求
[ZH] 他就是要走來教室
[ZH] 做四五十分鐘
[ZH] 然後你就是要
[ZH] 國中以前就是這些科目你都要讀
[ZH] 你功課你都要寫,你沒有得選擇
[ZH] 所以它的障礙就會比較明顯
[ZH] 右邊這邊,它是一個社群研究
[ZH] 它其實在講說你在社群裡面追蹤一群人
[ZH] 從3歲追蹤到17歲
[ZH] 然後一段時間就讓他們的家長
[ZH] 讓他們自己填一些量表
[ZH] 你可以發現有一部分的人
[ZH] 他其實一直都是處於最上面那條紅線
[ZH] 他一直都是處於比較明顯的症狀
[ZH] 然後會一直持續到17歲
[ZH] 可是有一群人像黃線這一群
[ZH] 它就會慢慢的緩解
[ZH] 它症狀就會越來越好
[ZH] 但是紫色的這一群
[ZH] 就是有一群人
[ZH] 其實反而是在小學中年級
[ZH] 高年級的時候
[ZH] 慢慢產現出它的困難
[ZH] 那這個通常是專注力不好的小朋友
[ZH] 就是學習的需求越來越高的時候
[ZH] 它的困難就會越來越被凸顯出來
[ZH] 而且生活治理上
[ZH] 你也會覺得一箇中年級的小朋友
[ZH] 高年級的小朋友
[ZH] 他應該要能夠行動這些事情
[ZH] 那怎麼他到現在還沒有辦法自己行動
[ZH] 什麼時間該做什麼事情
[ZH] 什麼事情要怎麼排序
[ZH] 讓事情可以順利一點
[ZH] 他自己明天要去上學
[ZH] 他要該帶什麼東西
[ZH] 然後整理好
[ZH] 他怎麼會不知道
[ZH] 還是弄得亂七八糟
[ZH] 那這些問題就會被突顯出來
[ZH] 那我不知道這邊各位在座
[ZH] 有沒有小小孩
[ZH] 我有時候在門診
[ZH] 就驚訝地發現
[ZH] 我們一二年級的小朋友
[ZH] 他們晚上的書包
[ZH] 都還是爸爸媽媽在整理
[ZH] 我很難理解
[ZH] 我自己有三個小孩
[ZH] 那我最小的小孩
[ZH] 現在也六年級
[ZH] 最大已經高一二
[ZH] 我從來沒有在幫他們整理書包的
[ZH] 那因為他們注意力沒有不好
[ZH] 所以他們自己可以就是整理的還可以這樣子
[ZH] 那可是有些媽媽就真的一路幫小孩整理到三年級還在整理
[ZH] 我不太理解他們為什麼要做這件事
[ZH] 那有些時候是互動的結果
[ZH] 就是你沒有幫他整理就發現他就出包了
[ZH] 然後就爆炸了這樣子
[ZH] 那你就要幫他送東西
[ZH] 所以就領課每天晚上前一天幫他整理這樣子
[ZH] 所以這個就是要去注意
[ZH] 然後其實可以提早訓練的東西啦
[ZH] 那但是呢
[ZH] 如果真的有做力不足的能力
[ZH] 就是怎麼訓練
[ZH] 你都會覺得很挫折
[ZH] 他就是會忘記
[ZH] 然後你就會覺得他的態度
[ZH] 就是好像不會要勿計這樣子
[ZH] 好
[ZH] 那他們其實呢
[ZH] 除了那個表型上
[ZH] 看起來行為上有些困難
[ZH] 其實他下面是有一些
[ZH] 中央執行工程的一些確損
[ZH] 包括工作記憶啊
[ZH] 剛剛曾主任跟我講
[ZH] 他的意志衝動能力
[ZH] 然後組織彈性啊
[ZH] 組織規劃的能力
[ZH] 都有些困難
[ZH] 我常常在講
[ZH] 我們的前河夜
[ZH] 是我們的CPU啦
[ZH] 就是我們大腦的處理系統
[ZH] 那你CPU的效能不好的時候
[ZH] 你其他的東西你就不用做了
[ZH] 那我們的那個CPU就是我們的理性大腦
[ZH] 就是閒額葉是我們的理性大腦
[ZH] 那理性大腦呢
[ZH] 它要做很多那個調
[ZH] 就是篩選掉雜訊
[ZH] 然後它要能夠去偵測到什麼訊息是有用的
[ZH] 然後什麼東西是衝動
[ZH] 這個衝動我要能夠把它壓抑下來
[ZH] 然後去思考這個情緒
[ZH] 我現在把它展現出來的時候
[ZH] 會不會對現在的情境
[ZH] 或是其他人造成什麼影響
[ZH] 這個都是你的潛而業在執行的功能
[ZH] 那一旦他功能不髒的時候
[ZH] 是不是你就跟動物一樣了
[ZH] 人之所以有人
[ZH] 是因為我們有高階的一些認知執行能力
[ZH] 當你這些東西功能削弱的時候
[ZH] 你就跟那些比較衝動的
[ZH] 那些動物不清思索
[ZH] 然後就是這樣子用直覺在做事
[ZH] 用情緒化在做事情的一些creature
[ZH] 可能差不多對不對
[ZH] 所以我常常跟家長講出說
[ZH] 我們應該要協助他去提升
[ZH] 他的前額頁的功能
[ZH] 那怎麼提升
[ZH] 其實最快的當然是藥物
[ZH] 那當然就是我們還有一些其他的
[ZH] 比如說那個運動啊
[ZH] 然後有一些認知操作的一些策略
[ZH] 的一些訓練啊
[ZH] 結構化環境的訓練啊
[ZH] 這個也都是我們可以做的事情
[ZH] 那這個
[ZH] 它的影響當然是一輩子的啦
[ZH] 不過我就不多講
[ZH] 因為講一都給大家
[ZH] 大家可以慢慢看這樣子
[ZH] 其實ADHD的小孩如果講白話一點
[ZH] 他們大概就是有這些狀況
[ZH] 像這一張大概就是過動衝動的一些狀況
[ZH] 他們就是蠻小的
[ZH] 然後就很衝動
[ZH] 然後想到什麼就做什麼
[ZH] 然後無聊就是過去就給你戳一下弄一下
[ZH] 然後他的充弟姐妹就哇哇叫
[ZH] 然後就開始吵架
[ZH] 姐妹就打回來
[ZH] 趕快他就打
[ZH] 找到戰場了
[ZH] 趕快就給他打回去
[ZH] 然後就開始吵起來了
[ZH] 那爸媽就會覺得每天晚上都會發生這種事情
[ZH] 他們實在是很受不了
[ZH] 那你問他說你為什麼要做這件事
[ZH] 他講得出來嗎
[ZH] 他們都跟你說我也不知道
[ZH] 然後家長就會很生氣
[ZH] 為什麼你不知道你在做什麼
[ZH] 老師也是一樣
[ZH] 他在學校的時候就會幹一些奇怪怪的事
[ZH] 什麼從二樓丟東西下去
[ZH] 幹個自由落體
[ZH] 一旦幾秒可以到地上這樣
[ZH] 對
[ZH] 還有丟水壺的
[ZH] 就非常危險嘛
[ZH] 被他炸到的是超倒黴的
[ZH] 對啊
[ZH] 然後你問他說你幹嘛做這件事
[ZH] 不知道
[ZH] 他就是越問越火這樣子
[ZH] 他不知道幹嘛做
[ZH] 他就不知道
[ZH] 真的不知道
[ZH] 因為他就是一時資訊
[ZH] 他能成為一個意念出來之後
[ZH] 他就去做了
[ZH] 他也沒有想說有什麼後果
[ZH] 他就只覺得好玩
[ZH] 他想要測試看看是什麼樣子
[ZH] 好玩
[ZH] 去戳別人也是
[ZH] 別人就嘩嘩叫
[ZH] 好玩
[ZH] 好像按完去
[ZH] 他會按了就會響
[ZH] 就會亮
[ZH] 他就有一種規律性
[ZH] 我就去給他弄一下
[ZH] 就過過過過這樣子
[ZH] 所以你也知道說
[ZH] 如果有在帶班
[ZH] 就是班上有些小孩就很愛去讓別人生氣
[ZH] 那有那種特別愛生氣的小孩
[ZH] 他就會被當成目標
[ZH] 然後就三不五十就可以就是有一個衝突這樣
[ZH] 就把他弄到那個生氣的小孩
[ZH] 會大吼啊甚至翻桌啊
[ZH] 就是那個比較給小的小孩去弄的這樣
[ZH] 但是你要幫他們隔開有時候就是也很難啊
[ZH] 因為給小的就很愛找那個喜歡生氣的
[ZH] 然後他們就是很難言之滿足啊
[ZH] 很怕無聊
[ZH] 所以他無聊的時候
[ZH] 他就會想去做一些什麼事
[ZH] 包括他摳指甲也是
[ZH] 很多摳指甲就會說
[ZH] 老醫生他是不是有焦慮症
[ZH] 為什麼最近一直摳成那樣
[ZH] 有些小孩的確是焦慮症
[ZH] 但是如果他有合併ATHD的時候
[ZH] 往往後來都變成壞習慣
[ZH] 因為你要他坐在教室裡50分鐘
[ZH] 他什麼事都不能做
[ZH] 他能幹嘛
[ZH] 可是他身上又想要動
[ZH] 不是抖腳
[ZH] 就是摳啊
[ZH] 對啊
[ZH] 不然就切橡皮擦嘛
[ZH] 有些都切到碎片
[ZH] 然後去弄他的自動鉛筆
[ZH] 然後彈簧就弄不見
[ZH] 類似這樣子的一個狀況
[ZH] 注意力不足的小朋友
[ZH] 他其實就是他們的
[ZH] 注意力的條件能力很差
[ZH] 他很難 精細度不好
[ZH] 他不知道什麼訊息
[ZH] 是他該注意的訊息
[ZH] 所以他訊息他常常就是這樣哄哄哄
[ZH] 他搞不清楚
[ZH] 然後另外有些會 hyper focus
[ZH] 就是說他在做什麼事情
[ZH] 叫他他好像都沒聽到
[ZH] 會選擇性失聰
[ZH] 然後媽媽就說
[ZH] 他要吃什麼東西馬上就聽到了
[ZH] 然後他在看電視的時候
[ZH] 我去叫他叫一百遍都不會聽到
[ZH] 就是這樣
[ZH] 因為他們的訊息篩選有一點狀況
[ZH] 那有些當然是故意的啦
[ZH] 有些是不想要理他媽這樣子
[ZH] 那再來就是說他們很難多工
[ZH] 因為他工作記憶不好
[ZH] 所以他很難從時間去操弄太多的訊息這樣
[ZH] 然後會注意力一轉移他就忘記了
[ZH] 然後他們常常多發胺不太夠
[ZH] 所以他們有那個動機
[ZH] 多發胺是我們的動機的一個神經推到握手
[ZH] 所以他不太夠的時候
[ZH] 他其實沒有一個能量跟一個想法
[ZH] 想要去做一件事情
[ZH] 所以就常常覺得他不要不停很散漫
[ZH] 人生沒有目標,很茫然會聰明
[ZH] 但是事實上是因為他們就真的沒有那個驅力
[ZH] 讓他們覺得滿足
[ZH] 那有一些人是他很想到處尋求刺激
[ZH] 因為他就會覺得平常的小確幸
[ZH] 一點都不幸福,超無聊
[ZH] 所以他就會想去做席線運動
[ZH] 做一些很刺激的會去飆車啊
[ZH] 然後從高的地方跳下來啊
[ZH] 去找一些事情做這樣子
[ZH] 那東西他們其實是沒有耐心好把它放好
[ZH] 而且他們其實沒有那個策略啦
[ZH] 他們不知道怎麼分類或怎麼放
[ZH] 會看起來比較整齊
[ZH] 那有時候有些人是可以啦
[ZH] 可以弄好
[ZH] 但是大概一天而已
[ZH] 然後就亂又開始亂了
[ZH] 他們喜歡用到哪放到哪
[ZH] 那這個是一個身體的困難
[ZH] 它不是意志力可以控制的
[ZH] 你知道嗎
[ZH] 其實在整間也是一樣
[ZH] 就已經在吃藥了
[ZH] 然後他就會說
[ZH] 你到底要吃藥吃多久
[ZH] 你為什麼不能用意志力控制一下
[ZH] 你長大了
[ZH] 應該可以自己努力看看這樣
[ZH] 那雖然是一個精神喊話
[ZH] 但是我會覺得說
[ZH] 有時候他們就是真的很難
[ZH] 如果說一個過動的小孩
[ZH] 他要靠意志力
[ZH] 可以坐在班上40分鐘
[ZH] 然後都不要亂動
[ZH] 不要在那邊摸東摸西東西
[ZH] 掉下去發出聲響
[ZH] 他要花很多力氣
[ZH] 去隨時注意他自己的動作
[ZH] 那這樣子他根本沒辦法上課
[ZH] 而且還會精神非常的緊繃
[ZH] 所以他有時候
[ZH] 有些小孩坐一坐
[ZH] 他需要站起來休息一下
[ZH] 你知道嗎
[ZH] 對 然後再坐下來
[ZH] 對 那就會
[ZH] 讓人家覺得很奇怪
[ZH] 每次幹嘛站起來
[ZH] 是因為他真的很努力在忍耐
[ZH] 但是他實在受不了了
[ZH] 所以就知道說
[ZH] 他們其實醫治醫是非常難控制的
[ZH] 然後這個是遺傳天生的
[ZH] 不是教養
[ZH] 因為很多媽媽就會說
[ZH] 是我懷孕過程怎樣
[ZH] 大部分都不是
[ZH] 然後說什麼
[ZH] 我是不是教養怎樣
[ZH] 就是被他太兇太嚴厲什麼的
[ZH] 但是其實就是
[ZH] 大部分是天生
[ZH] 其實很多一二一兩歲兩三歲
[ZH] 那個小孩的氣質你就看得出來
[ZH] 就是恰恰愛生氣
[ZH] 或是說是一個比較貼心的小孩
[ZH] 那時候兩三歲常常都看得出來了
[ZH] 但是不當的教養會惡化它的行為
[ZH] 所以我們為什麼要早期辨識
[ZH] 我們都說它可能是會帶著你一輩子的
[ZH] 那我們早期把它整斷去要怎麼用
[ZH] 是不是就早期介入嗎
[ZH] 去做OT嗎
[ZH] 做很多早期療愈嗎
[ZH] 其實很多早期療愈的ADHD的效果是有限的
[ZH] 因為它那個東西沒辦法類化
[ZH] 我們可以去練一些好的習慣
[ZH] 自我意志的行為觀察別人
[ZH] 聽訊息
[ZH] 執行策略
[ZH] 是可以稍微練一下
[ZH] 但是那個專注力的調控
[ZH] 並不是這樣就可以練好的
[ZH] 所以很多就是學齡前練了兩三年
[ZH] 然後到了小學之後還是得來吃藥這樣
[ZH] 他也是遇到很大的困難
[ZH] 那這個東西呢就是早期辨識要幹嘛
[ZH] 其實就是家長自己要能夠理解這個小孩
[ZH] 用比較合適的方式去跟他們互動
[ZH] 去教典他們
[ZH] 然後儘量避免製造他們的人生創傷
[ZH] 你知道這些小孩常常有很多micro trauma
[ZH] 就是他就三不十被罵
[ZH] 然後莫名其妙就被針對
[ZH] 真的會針對因為會有刻板印象
[ZH] 就你做壞事做多了
[ZH] 以後有任何一件壞事就是你做的
[ZH] 是不是
[ZH] 對啊
[ZH] 所以就是他們在人生的歷程中
[ZH] 常常被指責
[ZH] 然後被貶低
[ZH] 所以如果沒有早一點發現
[ZH] 他們這些慢慢的負面的經驗
[ZH] 會形述他後來的人格
[ZH] 所以我們早期發現的原因
[ZH] 是希望我們不要讓他開始出現
[ZH] 這些負面的
[ZH] 太多的負面經驗
[ZH] 然後讓他對自己很沒有自信
[ZH] 然後他就是開始會覺得
[ZH] 比較分屍技術
[ZH] 比較衝動
[ZH] 他就分屍技術
[ZH] 然後就覺得繁體質
[ZH] 什麼事都不要這樣子
[ZH] 那比較不衝動的
[ZH] 可能就會開始
[ZH] 就是會比較退縮
[ZH] 比較憂鬱
[ZH] 我剩一分鐘了
[ZH] 所以下次有機會再講
[ZH] 那治病症
[ZH] 剛剛那個
[ZH] 曾主任也講非常多了
[ZH] 那基本上大概就是
[ZH] 這個是診斷
[ZH] 然後這個辨識也越來越高
[ZH] 就是美國大概
[ZH] 現在好像三十二分之一
[ZH] 原因上面
[ZH] 雅思的辨識越來越多
[ZH] 那個Experger
[ZH] 比較高功能的
[ZH] 然後男生比女生是四分之
[ZH] 男生是四倍啊
[ZH] 女生的四倍這樣子
[ZH] 那最常被診斷的是加州
[ZH] 因為那邊有很多系谷
[ZH] 就是系谷嘛
[ZH] 系谷就有工程師很多嘛
[ZH] 工程師就會互相結婚
[ZH] 然後就會伸出
[ZH] 然後這個不是很好笑的事情
[ZH] 但是就是
[ZH] 就是說就是他就是基因
[ZH] loding很大的一個 condition這樣子
[ZH] 然後系谷的工程師也比較有錢嘛
[ZH] 他們可以帶小孩去做治療診斷這樣子
[ZH] 是這樣的關係
[ZH] 所以家族的診症率就很高這樣子
[ZH] 再來就是講它就還是
[ZH] GENETIC的因素佔很大
[ZH] 而且很多都是COMEON VARIANT
[ZH] 所以就是它潛藏在一般人的基因裡面
[ZH] 所以有時候爸媽就問我說
[ZH] 我跟我先生都沒有
[ZH] 為什麼我小孩用
[ZH] 它就是基因臭到了
[ZH] 有時候可能有自己的DINOMO
[ZH] 就是說新的突變
[ZH] 那個紅色是它自己的突變
[ZH] 所以有時候也沒有辦法去做什麼預防
[ZH] 或是什麼產天篩戒
[ZH] 那個都沒有辦法
[ZH] 而且它本身也有一些認知神經功能的一些困難
[ZH] 然後就是在某些processing
[ZH] 就是在這個是神經心理學家
[ZH] 他們自己定義出來的一些理論
[ZH] 他們就是心智理論有困難
[ZH] 他們在體系的處理上有困難
[ZH] 他們在感官知覺的處理上有困難
[ZH] 還有一些社交常識的一些概念
[ZH] 跟覺知也是會有一些困難這樣子
[ZH] 然後這是腦科學的證據
[ZH] 大家都自己看
[ZH] 如果就是想說看細節的話
[ZH] 他就把他丟到AI
[ZH] 然後AI就會跟你講這樣子
[ZH] 好
[ZH] 對那心智理論就是說
[ZH] 我們怎麼樣去感知別人的
[ZH] 就是知道別人的思路歷程
[ZH] 不是隻是表面上看出來的樣子
[ZH] 你會知道說他知道什麼
[ZH] 不知道什麼
[ZH] 我們ASD的小孩常常會理所當然認為
[ZH] 你應該知道他知道的事情
[ZH] 所以他講事情常常都講重點
[ZH] 然後他沒有再跟你講脈絡的
[ZH] 錢一或五都跟你講
[ZH] 那就是莫名其妙插一個東西給你
[ZH] 你就會想說
[ZH] 你其實說啥這樣子
[ZH] 那有耐性的
[ZH] 他就會開始知道他的困難
[ZH] 慢慢去引導他
[ZH] 人事實地悟
[ZH] 然後前面發生什麼事
[ZH] 然後你說這個
[ZH] 那後續你要幹嘛
[ZH] 那你就是要好好地跟他講
[ZH] 那ASD本身
[ZH] 他們就是有一些
[ZH] 就是他們在理解
[ZH] 學外之音的困難
[ZH] 所以有時候你跟他對話的時候
[ZH] 你會覺得牛頭不對馬嘴
[ZH] 因為你的重點是
[ZH] 他一直在執著在
[ZH] 你那個講話
[ZH] 一些字詞不夠精確
[ZH] 或是說他覺得
[ZH] 你這個講錯了
[ZH] 他就一直很糾結
[ZH] 你講錯了這件事情
[ZH] 不管說你大致上想要傳達的是
[ZH] 主要的概念是什麼
[ZH] 然後有時候就會吵起來
[ZH] 那這時候就要緩一緩
[ZH] 然後我們講錯的東西
[ZH] 我們就說就承認我們講錯了
[ZH] 對因為有時候真的不夠情趣
[ZH] 我們就是在只剩某個大的概念
[ZH] 但是它就是很善意跟精確的事情
[ZH] 那他們就是在情緒調節上面有一些困難
[ZH] 所以他們常常會有一些
[ZH] 就是很焦慮容易焦慮
[ZH] 或是容易暴怒的一些狀況
[ZH] 那本身就是
[ZH] 它就是一個光譜
[ZH] 所以說實話就是從很厲害的
[ZH] 然後社交的學習學得很好的
[ZH] 它偽裝的很好的那一種
[ZH] 那有些是到成人才會發現
[ZH] 就是他另外一半
[ZH] 或是他生出小孩
[ZH] 他才發現說自己可能是的
[ZH] 這個就是功能非常好
[ZH] 它偽裝的非常好
[ZH] 到非常功能低
[ZH] 就是不會講話
[ZH] 然後在地上一直玩
[ZH] 一些有的沒有的
[ZH] 敲敲打打
[ZH] 自我自己很多的那一種都有
[ZH] 都算是在ASD裡面這樣子
[ZH] 那這個東西就麻煩大家自己看哦
[ZH] 我就是寫中文都也寫的蠻詳細的
[ZH] 對
[ZH] 好
[ZH] 那他們
[ZH] 我覺得他們真的很tough啦
[ZH] 就是真的很辛苦這樣子
[ZH] 然後他們也要很努力
[ZH] 那就是要能夠預告啊接納
[ZH] 然後就要儘量結構化環境
[ZH] 然後環境的司機儘量弄得單純一點
[ZH] 然後他們有些routine
[ZH] 如果沒有無傷大人
[ZH] 不見得需要硬把它改掉這樣子
[ZH] 學長就不講了
[ZH] 基本上就是一個IQ正常
[ZH] 但是它在特定的學科有困難
[ZH] 有些是試字
[ZH] 有些是試字OK
[ZH] 但書寫不行
[ZH] 有些是數學量感
[ZH] 計算有一些困難的
[ZH] 這個大概要學校的特教系統
[ZH] 去協助做診斷這樣
[ZH] 我們醫療端大概就是
[ZH] 如果有公平ADHD
[ZH] 要治療ADHD這樣子
[ZH] 好
[ZH] 其實它們是蠻挫折的
[ZH] 然後會有一些輔助策略的這樣
[ZH] 學長大概不太能夠好
[ZH] 他就是用一些輔助策略
[ZH] 把他障礙的部分繞過去
[ZH] 他們其實神經重要性裡面
[ZH] 有40到50會有焦慮憂鬱的問題
[ZH] 他們常會用一些隱形的面貌
[ZH] 時間到了
[ZH] 他們不是不好
[ZH] 是有困難
[ZH] 需要被我們支援
[ZH] 接下來的課程就是
[ZH] 希望大家可以學到一些
[ZH] 大家外面的經驗
[ZH] 來協助支援我們的小孩
[ZH] 我是李玉如
[ZH] 謝謝大家來聆聽
[ZH] 好,謝謝林醫師
[ZH] 我們如果剛剛用測速照相機去拍林醫師的語速
[ZH] 應該紅單很多張
[ZH] 那個語速有超速這樣子
[ZH] 那因為他的內容非常的豐富
[ZH] 然後很希望大家可以有更多的認識
[ZH] 我們講神性多樣性的樣貌
[ZH] 那接下來我們就要講到一個很重要的講題
[ZH] 就是早上我們在講說
[ZH] 到底什麼是LIFE CODE
[ZH] 陪跑員
[ZH] 怎麼做一個陪跑員
[ZH] 或陪跑員應該要怎麼樣的一個技術
[ZH] 那接下來這個部分
[ZH] 我們就要邀請到我們國外的講者
[ZH] Berry Pell
[ZH] 然後我們會請我們的翻譯
[ZH] 在我們講者演講的過程中
[ZH] 會用中文
[ZH] 讓大家可以跟得上
[ZH] 講者簡報的這一個內容
[ZH] 那我們是不是歡迎我們的Berry
[ZH] 為我們進行下一段的演說
[ZH] 請不吝點贊 訂閱 轉發 打賞支援明鏡與點點欄目
[ZH] 請你進來是講的 謝謝
[EN*]  Hello, it's an honour to be with you here in Taiwan.
[EN*]  Thank you for inviting me to speak with you.
[ZH] Now several years ago, a Native American friend of mine honored me with a spirit out.
[ZH] 幾年前我有一個美國的原住民朋友,就是印第安朋友,送我一個守護靈獸的模型。
[ZH] 傳統上印第安人送動物的守護靈獸是想要告訴你是代表哪一種特定特質的動物,然後他給我一隻獅子。
[EN*]  But after everything I've eaten since arriving in Taiwan, I think my spirit animal has changed.
[EN*]  I think now I'm the hippopotamus.
[EN*]  Apparently, courage and strength is still there, but the evidence is becoming pretty obvious.
[EN*]  Imagine a 19-year-old, he has a smartphone, a laptop, high-speed internet, artificial
[EN]  intelligence, access to almost all of the world's knowledge, and yet, he cannot wake
[EN]  himself up in the morning. He avoids difficult conversations, and he's never learned how
[EN]  to resolve conflict face-to-face. He struggles to regulate anxiety, he cannot manage his
[ZH] 他有智慧型手機 電腦 網路 人工智慧
[ZH] 他隨時可以獲得全世界他想要的知識
[ZH] 但是他早上沒有辦法自己起床
[ZH] 然後他會去逃避困難的對話
[ZH] 他沒有辦法去面對面解決衝突
[ZH] 沒有辦法調節焦慮 管理時間
[ZH] 然後面對日常生活的責任
[ZH] 他卻覺得沒有辦法去負荷
[ZH] 他渴望獨立
[ZH] 可是他沒有辦法建立這些獨立所必要的技能
[ZH] 那如果20年前我描述剛才這樣講的一位年輕人
[ZH] 你們可能會覺得他是不是有什麼問題啊,心理疾病
[ZH] 可是今天呢,他其實是代表著越來越多青年族群的普遍現況
[ZH] 而且這並不是隻有美國才有的問題
[ZH] 他現在演變成一個全球性的挑戰
[ZH] 那關鍵問題在於是什麼改變造成這樣的現象
[ZH]  Now, over the past 20 years, we have made tremendous advances in treating mental illness
[ZH] 但在那一段時間,其他事件又發生了。
[ZH] 很多年輕人停止了一些技巧, 其他年代學習得到的。
[ZH] 今天,我會介紹你一個方法, 更加更加更新的。
[ZH] 生活技術教育。
[ZH] 不因為它會代表療療療, 但因為它會充滿了一個發展階段,
[ZH] 醫療沒有設計成了科學的科學
[ZH] 然而這個並不是要取代心理治療,而是為了要去填補心理治療沒有辦法涵蓋的這個斷層。
[ZH] 現在,在千萬年,年輕人看起來非常相似。
[ZH] 年輕人學習的做法,他們遭遇了問題,他們變得慘了,他們跟朋友們合作,他們抱歉,他們失敗了,他們回復了,他們活著,他們投資了,他們互動了。
[ZH] 就是數千年來青少年的成長其實是很類似的
[ZH] 就是年輕人都是從做中學
[ZH] 解決問題啊、體會無聊啊、跟朋友爭吵的過程中
[ZH] 就學會道歉、學會自己找解決的方法
[ZH] 然後遭遇失敗也可以找到重新振作的方法
[ZH] 然後去做事情、去從做中學協商溝通等等
[ZH]  Little by little, these ordinary experiences build extraordinary abilities.
[EN]  responsibility. These skills were rarely taught formally. They developed naturally.
[EN]  Then something changed. Technology transformed childhood. Again, technology is not the enemy.
[EN]  I use technology every day, and so do you.
[EN]  The issue isn't technology.
[ZH] 但是呢 因為科技改變了童年
[ZH] 那我要強調科技本身並不是我們的敵人
[ZH] 我們每天都在使用科技
[ZH] 那我的個案也是 我自己也是
[EN*]  Now, instead of face-to-face conversations, many conflicts now happen through text messages.
[EN*]  Instead of learning patience, everything arrives instantly.
[EN*]  Instead of experiencing boredom, every spare moment is filled with stimulation.
[EN*]  Instead of solving problems independently, young people often turn to Google,
[EN]  AI, or their parents. Instead of practicing difficult conversations, many avoid them altogether.
[EN]  Each individual change seems small, but together they alter development.
[EN]  One sentence summarizes this entire problem. Young people today have more information than any generation in history.
[EN]  But information is not the same as formation. Knowing something is not the same as becoming something.
[ZH] 知識的東西並非同樣的東西
[ZH] 然後呢,我們科技也取代了學習耐心
[ZH] 因為一切都是可以即時送到你面前
[ZH] 那科技也取代了體會無聊
[ZH] 因為每個空檔都被感官刺激也塞滿了
[ZH] 那科技也取代了獨立解決問題的能力
[ZH] 因為大家現在都很習慣第一時間就去問AI
[ZH] 那科技也取代了練習困難對話
[ZH] 就是很多人現在乾脆就是逃避啊,或是冷處理
[ZH] 所以這些改變看似微不足道
[ZH] 但是零零鐘總加起來
[ZH] 卻深刻改變了孩子的整體發展
[ZH] 我有句話可以來形容這個困境,現在年輕人擁有史上最多的豐富資訊,資訊的英文是Formation,但它並不能取代Formation,就是隻差了兩個英文字母,但Formation是人格養成的這個過程,所以知道某些知識並不代表你就可以成為一個具備相應能力的人。
[EN*]  So, knowing certain knowledge does not mean that you can have an effective ability.
[EN*]  Now, this brings us to an important distinction.
[EN*]  People often ask me, isn't coaching just another form of therapy?
[EN*]  And the answer is no.
[EN*]  Although they compliment each other rather beautifully,
[EN*]  Therapy asks, what is interfering with healthy functioning?
[EN*]  Life skills coaching asks, what skills still need to be developed?
[EN*]  Therapists treat psychiatric symptoms.
[EN*]  Coaches develop adaptive functioning.
[EN*]  Therapists reduce dysfunction.
[EN*]  Coaches increase capability.
[EN*]  Therapists help people heal.
[EN*]  Coaches help people grow.
[EN*]  Neither is better, and both are essential.
[EN*]  So, everyone will ask me, is that a life-sister, a life-sister, is another form of a mental health? That answer is not true. It is not true. It can be a good relationship. A life-sister will ask me what to do with my health and health. But a life-sister will ask me what to do with my health and health. But a life-sister will ask me what to do with my health and health. I will ask you what to do with my health and health. I will ask you what to do with my health and health. I will ask you what to do with my health and health.
[ZH] 心理治療師會問說是什麼阻礙我的當事人發揮健康的日常功能
[ZH] 但是呢生活陪跑師問的是
[ZH] 我的當事人還需要培養還有發展哪些生活技能
[ZH] 那治療師會專注在治療精神還有一些神經的病理症狀
[ZH] 但是生活陪跑師是專注於建立適應生活的功能還有能力
[ZH] 治療師會著重在減少這個失能障礙dysfunction
[EN*]  Now, let me give you an example.
[EN*]  Imagine a 17-year-old suffers from severe panic attacks.
[EN*]  That teenager needs therapy, possibly medication.
[EN*]  Now, imagine another 17-year-old.
[EN*]  No diagnosis, no trauma, no depression.
[EN]  He simply has part-time management skills.
[EN]  He can't organize his assignments, and he avoids responsibility.
[EN]  Has never learned how to solve interpersonal conflict.
[EN]  Now therapy may not be the answer. Life skills coaching probably is. One young person needs healing, the other needs development. Sometimes the same person needs both, and this is why collaboration between therapists and life skills coaches is becoming increasingly more valuable.
[ZH] 和生活教育教導師,可以更加值得更加值得。
[ZH] 心理治療可能就不是他需要的,生活導師的輔導才是。
[ZH] 那所以剛才講的這兩位孩子,第一位是需要就是療癒,
[ZH] 第一位一位孩子則是需要發展。
[ZH] 那有的時候有一個孩子他可能兩者都需要,
[ZH] 那也是為什麼我們心理治療師還有生活陪跑師之間的這個跨領域合作就是變得越來越重要。
[ZH] 那我認為每個年輕人都需要八個主要的生活核心技能
[ZH] 那當我在輔導年輕人的時候呢
[ZH] 我都會強調這些技能,那不是要去標籤化他們的人格,而是專注在這些技能的發展,因為技能是可以被學習還有練習的,那以下就是這八大技能。
[EN*]  Emotional regulation, learning to experience emotions without being controlled by them.
[EN*]  Executive functioning, planning, organization, time management, following through.
[EN*]  Communication, listening, speaking honestly, having difficult conversations.
[EN*]  Conflict resolution, disagreeing respectfully, repairing relationships, negotiating solutions.
[EN*]  Resilience, recover from setbacks, persisting through difficulty, learning that failure is information not identity.
[EN*]  healthy relationships, boundaries, empathy, trust, respect, purpose and goal setting, living intentionally, making decisions based on values instead of emotions.
[EN*]  Personal responsibility. Taking ownership. Keeping commitments. Learning that freedom always comes with responsibility.
[EN*]  Notice something. None of these are psychiatric treatments. They're life competencies. Yet they drastically and dramatically improve mental health.
[EN*]  and you can understand the rights of the human being and the human being.
[ZH] 可以從根本上改善心理健康
[?EN]  I need to be more organized.
[?EN]  I need to stop procrastinating.
[?EN]  I need to make better decisions.
[?EN]  And yet, they continue to struggle.
[?ZH]  continue to struggle. This can be incredibly frustrating for parents. They may say, he knows
[?EN]  This can be incredibly frustrating for parents.
[?EN]  They may say, he knows exactly what he's supposed to do.
[?ZH]  exactly what he's supposed to do. Why doesn't he just do it? That's a very important question.
[?EN]  Why does he just do it?
[?EN]  That's a very important question.
[?EN]  The answer is that knowing is a cognitive skill. Doing is a performance skill. There is a significant distance between the two.
[?ZH]  The answer is that knowing is a cognitive skill. Doing is a performance skill.
[ZH]  There is a significant distance between the two.
[ZH] 就是知道還有做到,其實之間是存在一個巨大的鴻溝
[ZH] 就是年輕人心裡可能會知道說,我要控制我的脾氣啊
[ZH] 我要做事更有條理啊,不要拖拖拉拉,我希望做出更好的決定
[ZH] 可是他們還是會就是很掙扎,那讓他們的忠譽很掙扎
[ZH] 那爸媽媽常會想說,他明明都懂,為什麼就做不到
[EN*]  The answer is,
[EN*]  knowing is a cognitive skill.
[EN*]  Knowing is a way to do it.
[EN*]  And being able to do it is a way to do it.
[EN*]  It is a big difference.
[EN*]  Now, a young person may understand that exercise is good for them,
[EN*]  and still not exercise.
[EN*]  They may understand that sleep matters,
[EN*]  And still, they stay up all night.
[EN*]  They may know that yelling at their parents is not helpful.
[EN*]  And still yet, that's all they do.
[EN*]  The problem isn't always a lack of knowledge.
[EN*]  Sometimes the problem is that the skill has not yet become automatic.
[EN*]  That is where life skills coaching becomes so important.
[EN*]  skills must be practiced under stress. Now a student may demonstrate excellent emotional regulation in coaching or therapy. They can explain, when I'm angry, I should pause, I should do it.
[EN*]  take a breath and communicate my feelings. Well, that's wonderful. Now let's see what
[EN*]  happens when their phone is taken away. Their parents say no. A peer insults them. They
[EN]  receive a bad grade. They're told to go to bed. They lose a privilege. This is the real
[EN]  test. We don't want to know whether a student can describe emotional regulation. We want
[EN]  know whether they can use emotional regulation when emotionally dysregulated. That is a very
[EN]  different thing. This is why real-world practice is so important. The therapy room teaches the skill,
[ZH] 生命侶控制採討。
[ZH] 那一個年輕人的話,他可能可以很自信的告訴你說
[ZH] 當我生氣的時候,我應該要暫停下深呼吸,然後好好說出我的感受
[ZH] 理想上是這樣子,但是當真實生活的情境的時候
[ZH] 當這個人的手機被沒收,當有人告訴他不行
[ZH] 當他考試不及格,被要求立刻去上桶睡覺
[ZH] 或是失去某項特權的時候,這才是真正考驗的來臨
[ZH] 我們不是單純要求年輕人用言語敘述來調節情緒要怎麼做,而是要知道他可不可以在情緒失控的當下,他可以實際運用這些調節技巧,這是兩件不同的事情,所以治療是傳授技能,然後真實生活才是真正的考驗的場所。
[ZH] So quick question, imagine a 16 year old student understands that he needs to improve his organisation.
[EN]  He's been taught to use a calendar, maybe even a daily planner.
[EN]  He agrees that organization is important.
[EN]  However, he regularly forgets assignments, loses the materials, and misses deadlines.
[EN]  Is this primarily a mental health problem or a life skills problem, or both?
[EN]  And the answer is probably both.
[EN]  Maybe the student has ADHD, maybe he's anxious, maybe he's depressed.
[EN]  Maybe he has poor executive functioning.
[EN]  But the solution still requires him to develop a practical system for managing his life.
[EN*]  Diagnosis may explain the problem, but skills create a solution.
[EN*]  It's a two-step process. This student may have ADHD, or a mental illness, or a simple practice.
[EN*]  The solution is to help him to create a system of care and care.
[EN*]  So, the treatment can be solved by the problem, but the ability can be created by the real solution.
[EN*]  One of the most important questions in treatment and coaching is,
[EN*]  can the young person transfer the skill?
[EN*]  Now, a student may be able to regulate therapy,
[EN]  organize with a coach,
[EN]  even communicate respectfully with a therapist,
[EN]  maybe complete assignments with constant supervision.
[EN]  But what happens when support is removed?
[EN]  We should gradually ask, can he do it with help?
[EN]  Then, can he do it with a reminder?
[EN]  Then, can he do it independently?
[EN]  And finally, can he do it when life becomes difficult?
[EN]  That is the progression from treatment to independence.
[ZH] 他可以整理規劃
[ZH] 他跟心理師的時候
[ZH] 溝通的時候他是很有禮貌的
[ZH] 然後他也可以在全程監督下完成作業
[ZH] 可是當我們把這些外在支援都拿掉的時候
[ZH] 會發生什麼事
[ZH] 所以我們應該要循序漸定的去檢視說
[ZH] 第一步他在有人協助的狀況下可不可以做到
[ZH] 那沒人協助但是有人提醒的話
[ZH] 他可不可以做到
[ZH] 那接下來下一步
[ZH] 沒人提醒他可以獨立做到嗎
[ZH] 然後最後一步就是
[ZH] 當他面臨壓力還有掙扎的時候
[ZH] 他可以做到嗎
[ZH] 這就是讓孩子從依賴治療 邁向獨立不足的過程
[EN]  person 6 months after discharge. Now that question changes the way we approach everything. It changes how we teach organization, how we teach emotional regulation, communication, and how we teach responsibility.
[ZH] 我們的目標不是說他在這邊可以表現得很好而已
[ZH] 而是他可不可以將在這邊學到的能力帶回他的家庭、學校、職場還有人際關係中繼續運用
[ZH] 所以我們必須要不斷地自問說
[ZH] 我們今天做的事情在結案或是孩子離開機構六個月後
[ZH] 是否還可以實質幫助到這個孩子
[ZH] 那這個問題會改變我們教學還有介入的所有方式
[ZH] 我們不只是想讓學生成功成功,我們不只是要讓孩子在我們的機構環境中表現成功,而是讓我們這個環境對他們來說越來越不需要,所以聽起來有點矛盾,這其實就是我們實際的期許,就是我們工作做得越好,
[ZH] 那年輕人對我們的依賴越少 這樣實在是最好的
[ZH] 那我將技能發展規劃成五個階段
[ZH] 第一個是理解 那年輕人應該要學習還有理解這項技能到底是什麼
[EN*]  Practice, the young person tries the skill in a supported environment.
[EN*]  Then practice, the young person tries the skill in a supported environment.
[ZH] 第三個階段是他會去遇到挫折
[ZH] 他可能會遭遇失敗
[ZH] 然後會感到很不知所措
[ZH] 接下來他會去檢討發生了什麼挫折
[ZH] 怎麼去修復 然後從中學習要再次嘗試
[ZH] 然後再重複重複內化這些過程
[ZH] 直到他可以學習到這些技能
[ZH] 最終達到努力自尊的階段
[ZH] 所以就是不斷的理解 練習 掙扎 修復
[ZH] 重複內化
[ZH] 這就是帶來真實改變的完整理想
[EN]  But sometimes failure is the most important part of development.
[EN]  A student forgets an assignment. A conflict happens. A student loses the privilege. A family conversation goes poorly. The question is not, how do we make sure this never happens again? The better question is, what can the student person learn from what just happened? We don't want to remove every consequence from a person's life. We want to help them learn how to respond to consequences.
[ZH] 然後家庭對話陷入僵局
[ZH] 那關鍵問題其實並不是我們要讓這件事不會再發生
[ZH] 其實更好的問題是這個年輕人可以從這些經驗裡面學到什麼
[ZH] 所以我們不應該替孩子掃除人生中所有的後果
[ZH] 而是要陪伴他如何學會還有面對承擔這些後果
[ZH] 因為生日後療療程會仍然避免失敗
[ZH] 失敗、失敗、失敗、失敗、不期待的改變
[ZH] 因為真實人生其實是充滿衝突,失敗還有挫折,甚至是突如其來的變故,所以我們的目標不是為孩子創造一個無風無雨的人生,而是要培養出一個可以應對逆境的人。
[ZH] 那任何發生重大的事件或衝突的時候,我們可以引導詢問這四個關鍵的問題,第一個是發生了什麼事,然後請他釐清客觀的事實。
[EN*]  第二問題是問她說你當時的感受是什麼,讓她去覺察情緒。
[EN*]  第三個問題是你那時候做了什麼事情,那這是要讓她承擔責任。
[EN*]  And what will you do next time? Life skills.
[ZH] 這個簡直的細節 連線了健康治療與實驗的發展。
[ZH] 它移動了年輕人從這件事發生的事件到這件事件,我所提供的事件,我可以學習,我會選擇的事件。
[ZH] 這是個人的社會主義主義主義。
[ZH] 誒,這件事情發生在我身上,我是一個受害者,轉變成,誒,這件事情發生了,那我在其中也是有責任,我可以從中學習,而且下一次要怎麼做,我是有選擇權的。
[ZH] 那這個就是Personal Agency,就是個人主體,個人主體能動的開端,就是自己選擇權都在自己手上。
[ZH] 現在,為什麼要這個問題?
[ZH] 我希望你兩種未來的目標
[ZH] 一種,我們只要問我們如何處理 mental病毒?
[?EN]  how do we treat mental illness?
[?EN]  This is an important question, but it's incomplete.
[?ZH] 這是一個重要的問題,但它是不足的問題
[?ZH] 我想另一個未來的目標
[?EN]  I imagine another future where we also ask,
[?ZH] 我們也問我們要為我們要建立健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康健康 statements
[?EN]  how do we intentionally build mentally healthy adults?
[?EN]  That changes everything.
[?EN]  Instead of waiting until the crisis, we prepare before the crisis, we help things go right.
[?EN]  Instead of only treating problems, we build strengths.
[?ZH] 不可以提出自己事情嗎?
[?EN]  Instead of asking, what's wrong with a young person?
[ZH] 我們問我們我們問我們什麼事情的需要教學?
[ZH] 那這轉變是我們看到整個世代的變化
[ZH] 被動的等待危機爆發轉變成危機來臨前我們就可以做好完全的準備
[ZH] 然後從以前只會專注於治療問題和症狀轉變成要建立個案的優勢能力
[ZH] 然後從以前這個孩子到底有什麼問題
[ZH] 轉變成問我們自己說這個孩子還有哪些生活技能還沒有被教導建立
[ZH] 那這樣的思維轉變就會改寫我們去看待去對待新世代的一個方式
[EN*]  It's not simply does the young person behave better, although that matters too.
[EN*]  The deeper question is, is this young person becoming more capable of managing his own life?
[EN*]  can he identify what he has been? Communicate what he needs? Manage his time, solve problems, tolerate frustration, maintain relationships, accept responsibility, make decisions, recover from mistakes, that is where mental health and life skills come together.
[EN*]  The question is not simply does he function well whilst someone is helping him, the question
[EN*]  is is he becoming capable of helping himself?
[EN*]  That's the key.
[EN*]  and how to manage your life and manage your life.
[EN*]  These are the指標.
[EN*]  How can you feel your emotions and feelings?
[ZH] 可不可以承擔責任,可不可以自行做出明智的決定,可不可以從錯誤還有失敗中去復原
[ZH] 那這就是心理健康還有生活技能交會的核心所在
[ZH] 所以關鍵不是在有人協助的狀況下他可以表現得很好
[ZH] 而是他有沒有正逐漸講出可以幫助自己的福利
[EN*]  I'd like to leave you with one high and flow, so healthy builds are not wrong, they're developed.
[EN*]  For generations, families, schools, communities, and life itself naturally developed many of the skills young people needed.
[EN*]  But today's world is very different.
[EN*]  that doesn't make this generation weaker it simply means they need more intentional guidance
[EN*]  that is where life skills coaching has an important role not replacing therapy not replacing parents
[ZH] 而是跟我們三個人合作,
[ZH] 因為每個人都得到更多的症狀態。
[ZH] 他們得到能力,
[ZH] 肯定,
[ZH] 求求,
[ZH] 和希望。
[ZH] 我們經歷了一段時間問,
[ZH] 我們如何去治癒 mental illness?
[ZH] 今天,我推薦一個很重要的問題,
[ZH] 我們如何去建議 mental wellness?
[ZH] 好,那最後我想要給大家一個核心的訊息
[ZH] 就是身心健全的成年人其實不是天神與生俱來的
[ZH] 而是要被培育出來的
[ZH] 那在過去的時代,家庭、學校、社群
[ZH] 還有真實生活的本身會很自然的去鍛造
[ZH] 去鍛煉年輕人所需要的各種生存還有適應的技能
[ZH] 但是我們現在活在一個不一樣的世界
[ZH] 那這個世界就是不表示說年輕人就是比較脆弱
[ZH] 而是代表年輕人需要更多有意識
[ZH] 有系統去引導他們
[ZH] 那這陣子就是生活
[ZH] 陪跑時扮演關鍵角色的地方
[ZH] 就是不是要取代心理治療
[ZH] 不是要取代父母學校教育
[ZH] 而是大家都一起攜手建立強大的夥伴關係
[ZH] 因為每一個神經多樣性
[ZH] 還有面臨挑戰的年輕人
[ZH] 他們所值得擁有的
[ZH] 不是隻有精神症狀的環節
[ZH] 而是他們很值得擁有實際能力
[ZH] 自信心,復元力,人生目標和希望。過去數十年來我們會探討如何治療心理症狀和疾病。
[EN*]  So, over the last 10 years, we will always look at how to treat mental health and mental health.
[EN*]  So how do we intentionally build mental wellness?
[EN*]  Well, I believe Life Skills Coaching is one more important answer.
[EN*]  Because therapy may help someone heal, but Life Skills Coaching helps people prepare for life.
[ZH] Healthy adults are not born
[ZH] They are intentionally developed
[ZH] Thank you very much
[ZH] 所以我再問一次這個問題
[ZH] 就是我們如何有意思的去建議心理健康還有全人福祉
[ZH] 我認為生活培託師會是一個關鍵的答案
[ZH] 因為心理治療可以幫助一個人療癒心理的創傷
[ZH] 但是生活培託師可以幫助孩子
[ZH] 為未來真實的人生做好準備
[ZH] 所以我想要再次用我剛才的核心訊息
[ZH] 來總結這場分享
[ZH] 就是身心健全的成年人不是天生的
[ZH] 而是我們需要有意識的去培養出來
[ZH] 謝謝大家
[ZH] 好
[ZH] 謝謝Berry
[ZH] 謝謝Amoly
[ZH] 那以上
[ZH] 延續三位講者
[ZH] 非常精彩的分享以後
[ZH] 我們有十分鐘的休息時間
[ZH] 早上有一些假點
[ZH] 大家可以取用